the massive influx of migrants arriving
in Denver is pushing that Health System
to its Breaking Point the Denver healthc
care system is now saying that it has
provided more than $130 million of
medical care that it still has not
received payment for with thousands of
migrants contributing to that bill
joining us now with an update is Stephen
federo Chief government and Community
Affairs officer for Denver Health Health
sir thank you very much for joining us
first off what exactly is happening with
the with the health care in that
hospital can somebody who's showing up
right now that needs care get
it yeah thank you for having us Sandra
um so Denver Health is very proud of
it's 160-year mission of uh providing
Health Care to people in Denver
regardless of their ability to pay uh
just to correct one fact you know last
year we did provide $130 million of
uncompensated care um and a small
portion of that uh is related to the
recent arrival of many migrants but the
Baseline uh for our Hospital uh was at
$130 million prior to the arrival of
this population okay um that would be an
important clarification so you're saying
that all these migrants that are showing
up the at the hospital are not rcking up
big bills no they absolutely are
contributing to that we estimate that
we've seen about 8,000 of these newly
arrived migrants in our hospital system
from emergency rooms to Primary Care to
dental clinics
um and of course uh the lack of a
federal response uh to the healthcare
needs of this population uh results in
their inability to pay for the majority
of this care so it has contributed to
our financial distress to be clear what
do you think the federal government is
responsible for how should it be
stepping in here well I think we need to
provide basic needs to to these to these
populations you know they are they are
coming to our hospital as patients um
with uh basic healthc care needs such as
respiratory illness GI illnesses some of
them have Baseline chronic illnesses
such as asthma and diabetes we're seeing
severe dental disease in the population
some of them have acute illnesses as a
result of their arduous Journey living
in un sanitary conditions drinking poor
drinking water and so we're doing the
best we can from a clinical standpoint
to take care of them but we really need
a a system in place to help pay for that
medical care to make sure that these
patients get the needed care get the
needed medication get the needed
followup and the lack of a of a
structured system to pay for that is
making it extremely difficult for our
clinical teams what do you say to some
who might say that structured system
should be our secured borders um the
they're they're coming in because they
can and they're coming in and and Texas
has been inundated their resources are
dried up their hospitals are overflowing
their cities are are paying a huge
economic price and so now they're going
to other cities and now this is falling
in the lap of Denver and and as far as
we are being told your health care
system is is is
inundated yeah a huge shout out to our
May mayor and our federal delegation for
calling on uh the federal government to
support uh this population as they await
um additional uh policies that will call
for their their long-term viability in
this country but I do think it's
important that we need to provide social
infastructure for them places to stay
food for them to eat and and Healthcare
Healthcare needs to be a key component
to the response of this population and
obviously and that is that is your job
and we understand that there's there's a
huge economic concern there's only so
much that our system will be able to
bear and and many others will have to
pay for that eventually and that is a
question where does that money money
come from your mayor uh Johnston who you
just referenced he said that there's a
big problem with the lack of work
permits for these migrants in what he
called was a broken federal system
listen
here it is unsustainable in the current
structure when we have 30 or 40,000
people arriving without work
authorization without Federal support it
is going to be a huge strain on cities
if you send us someone to Denver who has
to wait 6 years for a court hearing and
they can't work in the meantime we're
going to need almost endless amounts of
federal support I don't think that's
what we want or the federal government
wants so it it feels like what he's
pointing to is the process here when
you've got all these tens of thousands
of people arriving without work
authorization without Federal support um
this is a huge strain on the local level
of so many of these cities who who have
said we welcome
everyone yeah we're proud to stand with
the mayor in response to this
humanitarian crisis and we absolutely
need additional funding to provide a a a
sustainable infrastructure to support
their path forward I agree I think um uh
allowing them to work is absolutely a
part of the next steps that it's going
to take to uh to provide the funding but
we also need Federal support in the
meantime most especially around around
the healthare cost you know our staff
are being asked to to staff up see extra
patients and then you know the moral
Strife that comes with discharging a
patient not knowing if they're going to
have the money they need to fill that
needed prescription find transportation
to a follow-up care come back for
additional care it's extremely strenuous
on our staff and I really feel for them
do do you have any doctors who are
saying they just can't do it anymore
that it's just too much I mean is there
staff that are saying that they're
leaving no uh our staff are very proud
to um to fulfill the mission of Denver
Health to provide care to everyone
regardless of their ability to pay uh
very much um responding to the
humanitarian crisis of these patients we
understand but we're going to need
additional support to do it and to do it
well I and have have you had to turn
away any
patients no so we'll always see patients
most especially through the emergency
department which is where we're seeing
the vast majority of these patients
currently oh okay so the because the
headline everywhere right now is that
you've had to turn away patients is that
not the case no we always see patients
um through the emergency department
regardless of their ability now our
ability to see them followup is
extremely limited based on physical
capacity and the lack of resources to do
so understood we thank you for your time
sir you have a huge task at hand
appreciate your time thank you very much
thank you for covering the story I
appreciate you I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and I'm Angley Airhart and click
here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis